So which of these problems here are computer problems? So, let's just check the three rules.
Given an essay by a student, that is definitely a finite string using a constant number of symbols.
So rule 1 here is okay. Does that essay have at least 10,000 characters?
Where the output is same, either yes or no?
So that is easily fulfill-able and of course the answer here is also objectively correct.
You can easily count the number of characters and say, yes it's at least 10,000 or no, it's not.
So this is definitely a computer problem.
The second, one of course, well, the output would still be a finite string,
because you could say depending on the grading system, A, B, C, D, or 1, 2, 3, 4,
of course, the output is not objectively correct because different instructors
tend to sometimes at least disagree on the grade that an essay deserves.
So this is not a computer problem although there have been attempts for
automated grading which is just weird to say at least.
Does the essay contain any misspelled words? Now this is a tricky one.
So the input again is finite. The output basically just says yes or no or it can even specify the word.
The problem is that it's sometimes very hard to say if something is a spelling mistake.
I'll give you one example. Consider for example this sentence here.
He was attacked by a rat.
At first sight, this sentence--at least if I'd written it in the correct way--
does not contain any misspelled words, but actually it could contain a misspelled word,
because what if the author actually had meant to type he was attacked by a bat.
That sentence by itself might make perfect sense but you could still have
simply mistyped this word here although of course your computer has a spell checker,
you might've noticed that the spell checker sometimes is wrong
because it sometimes just cannot figure out in which context your saying your sentence.
And even if it were a very very strong computer and this example here,
you cannot objectively determine if this is the right answer.
It can be dependent more or less totally on the author.
This problem here is actually not a computer problem in the way that it's stated here.
But this was a bit of a tricky one, so I hope you're not frustrated if you didn't get that.
But it tells you that sometimes you have to watch out very careful with these rules.
They sound very simple but actually there are some tricky details seen in here.
So let's go to the next set of problems. Given two integers, what is their sum?
That, of course, is a very classic computer problem.
The integers are given as numbers 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. The output is a number that's also fine. It's finite.
And adding something where you can definitely have a definitive and objective answer.
Does the smaller integer divide the larger one? Yes absolutely a computer problem.
The answer is yes or no and you can objectively say if the answer is correct or no.
This one down here is not a computer problem and actually
it's not a computer problem for two reasons.
One reason which is a bit technical is the RAM computer
or a normal computer doesn't really have true randomness.
A normal computer generates numbers that seem like random
using an algorithm but that is not random, but as I said this is a bit technical.
I think the main reason why this is not a computer problem is that it's not possible
once you have the answer to actually know if this answer is correct.
So if the number was indeed generated at random. So let me give you one example.
So for example, I have the numbers 7 and 10, and now I say that
I have randomly generated a 9 which lies between the two.
You have no way of checking this I really generated this number using coin flips,
or throwing a dice, or if I just made that up, or maybe if I use an algorithm that always outputs a 9.
So there's no way to determine from an output if that output
has really been generated using a random process.
And that is basically also the same reason why this one here is not correct.
Of course you can kind of determine the likelihood if this is a very long string of 0s and 1s,
you can say well this looks more or less like a random string or not random string,
but actually if the string is generated choosing uniformly between 0s and 1s,
any string is as likely as any other string, so it's not possible to objectively check the answer yes.
So for example, if I say I generated a string using a number of coin flips
and I have heads, heads, heads, heads, heads, heads, heads, heads,
it might not look random but maybe I was just lucky at that moment.
Now the final answer here and if you got that right without checking this answer video,
then you're almost a master of theoretical computer science
because this again is a quite tricky one in my mind.
I will tell you that this is not a computer problem. Why is that not a computer problem?
You can enter a √5 into your computer, which you need to do like this, into Google for example,
and then we'll tell you that the √5 is 2.23606798 but that is actually not the correct answer.
For example, if I enter it into another calculator or webpage that has more digits,
then that will tell me that it's actually not 6798, but actually
2.23606606797749978969640917366973 and so on.
The √5 is an infinite string. If I ask a computer to calculate √5 to within a certain position,
say, I want the first 10 digits or so, then it is a computer problem
but just asking a computer to calculate the √5, then this way is not correct.
Why am I nitpicking you here like this?
Well the thing is this, infinities will play a very important role here in this unit
when it comes to problem set no computer can ever solve.
This is why it's very important to make sure that the input is finite and the output is finite.
So if you do not phrase the question here very precisely,
then some of the results will change or not be correct.
So, it's very important to ensure finiteness and later in this unit you will see why it's so important.